when the first lockdown hit do you get  stuck in america  yeah i got stuck in him and i i don't i  find america quite hard sometimes  because i'm very  english and i would just like to say you  saved my life when i was in america  seriously swear to god i was like i was  missing fish and chips  i was missing pints a lager like people  in hollywood they're not very like got  british humor average i mean you can't  tell someone in hollywood the feet stink  they'll still be like you'll just look  at yourself funny it's like  it's like it's like even if someone's  feet stink in america it's like oh my  god hi  like your feet are amazing i mean  i was sat in the aisles bingeing peep  show  yeah i mean ma'am to send me chocolate  hobnobs across the ocean  wanting to get home alan bennett in 50  [Laughter]  years  very glad i was able to help destroy the  whole hollywood vibe  you just burned that it was just like  you just like  i loved it  you